today we are drawing characters in our
own style
from the wheel from the wheel our iconic
styles
random characters spin a big wheel
see who we get all right jackie give it
a spin i will
i will kevin
this is very stressful
that's okay yeah peach all right i can
do princess peach
all right oh boy
[Music]
[Applause]
yes okay do you watch one punch man i do
i've never seen frozen just trust your
gut and let it go
okay let's do it i have not seen a lot
of simpsons i feel like i watched
simpsons but like like peripherally are
you a mario fan
yes i love mario games i love it how
about you
uh mario kart all the way okay so i'm
gonna actually try
not looking at the reference because i
want this to be a brent
original drawing i definitely want her
to have a giant head
i wouldn't say that she didn't have a
giant head but i'm going big
but i think i'm going to keep all her
coloring the same she's got cute big
blue hair
right she looks like she's having a
really good time just being a mom
okay what does she do does she have a
job she's a stay-at-home mom that's her
thing
yeah i love that chaser bliss marge when
i was a kid
i was like addicted to the you know the
90s era
of comic books where everyone had like
unrealistic proportions
as a cartoonist i would say my style is
pretty cartoony but based on
solid illustrative construction so like
i'm not
doing a whole lot of exaggeration in
terms of the proportions
he is so iconic and perfect like he's
a good blend of simple but incredibly
memorable
he's got his red white and blue colors
his overalls his adorable mustache
big nose hat his shapes are so good
so i guess i'll just kind of make him a
little cartoonier
like cuter cartoonier how did i develop
my style
i watched a lot of anime really just
so much of it you say it's anime
influenced yeah
pretty much yeah i love anime still do
you gonna redesign peach's dress in any
way
yes does princess peach like have a
sword from my knee
it's in your style jason do whatever you
want
draw her with a sword eleven minutes
okay
that's quite not a lot of time i feel
like but you know what
i believe in us i do believe this i'm
moving on to inking
inking already jackie i notice when you
ink you use colored lines
i do that's one of my favorite things to
do with lines
this color is that an animator thing i
don't think so i think that's just
something i like
learned as like a teenager and then i
continued to do because i like the
the results of them did you grow up
drawing digitally yes
i sure did really yeah i'm not that
great with traditional
art really yeah but i mean i can do it
but not as good as
i can do things digitally i rarely
color my lines because again i come from
the world of print
and so i'm always thinking about what is
going to make
the cleanest black line yes i respect
that i respect your
artistic upbringing i respect
your need for speed man i don't
i feel like i don't have much of a style
like i feel like it's definitely like
90s cartoon inspired
like they have a lot of construction
like in terms of like shapes and like
form but then like i also like to just
like
throw in weird perspective things that
don't make sense
i can describe kira's style very
well it is very clean it's amazing
she has amazing arcs of motion you
always choose to
um like keep things within not
monochromatic
but uh like within one limited color
palette limited like a limited color
palette yeah
the animation way z style i'm just
getting familiar with
today even though i've known you for a
while because you
never draw but um your style is adorable
it completely has like that mascot
appeal
like that adorable japanese mascot
appeal who should he be punching
maybe he's punching my bugs bunny i was
just about to say that
and i'm happy you uh brought it up from
china
that have like followed this series they
will know what i'm drawing
and it's my disgusting attempt at a bugs
bunny
i would say if you really want to get
into animation just draw
all the time just like you know bring a
sketchbook with you anywhere
watch youtube videos like there's so
many available resources to learn
you can look up anything and like super
specific and just be like i want to
learn how to draw
this or this style or draw like this
you know disney like animator you can
just go find and they probably have like
classes online or their own website or
blog or whatever that you can go
look at that's pretty amazing i should
have
done a lot simpler of a design
but you know what because my style is
complicated
just like you right as a person you know
thank you you've got a lot of different
feelings
a lot of different emotions your art
style reflects who you are
she's so cute like i like her because
she's like
she's a feminine woman but she's not
like
i'm just gonna sit around and like wait
for mario to do everything for
me it's like she will take things into
her own hands if she has to
like she gets true she's a good role
model yeah so what is princess peach
doing in your drawing
she's holding a sword and her her hair
is just being really epic right now
okay yeah so i'm having a lot of fun
with the
just the lines on the hair i'm having
fun beating up my own drawing
that's probably my favorite part of this
two more minutes
okay well i just feel like that's quite
rude i forgot her crown
this is a trap oh she's a princess
all right i'm i'm satisfied i didn't
give her any
skin color oh just gonna be snow white
done i think i did
pretty darn good working off of a
reference picture
sure makes it a lot easier to just sort
of concentrate on the drawing itself
i think i did okay i think she looks
like shira meets princess peach
is what i drew it's a little wonky okay
but
i think the energy of it is cute i think
mine has elsa vibes i'm not totally
happy
with the pose i would say i can do
better
you got it come on this is great i love
this
i love this here's what i love about
yours she's got like a nice line of
action
i love her smile dude this is wild i
love your
you got this like epic comic book
perspective on all your drawings
it's coming at me dude i'm feeling this
dude you got her like hair
which is sort of mimicking the motion of
the flames
i feel her like vengeance you know i
like that he's punching out your bugs
bunny's tooth
the the blood and the blood on this is
great i think you really did reimagine
him
like it's clearly him but then it's like
this is cool i can see the cure in it
with like the clean lines but actually
this is kind of different
i think for you like love it thank you
so much for the good job
yours is so adorable i love like the
flow of her shape and i love that she's
like
tiny she's so cute i think like the
colors stand out super well
you got her you got her smirk you got
her ice magic very pretty
you got her cute little cape you got her
cute little dress yeah
did a good job this exercise was really
hard because it's like how do you
improve upon characters that are like
the embodiment of perfection like their
designs are so iconic and so ingrained
in our culture
that it's like it's really hard to try
to come up with like a
different appealing interpretation of
them and i think that's the most fun
part of
drawing fan art is that you can make
your own interpretation
on something you love as a little homage
hey what's up i'm jackie and i'm kevin
today we're going to be drawing random
characters in our own style
from the wheel the wheel that's how
drying works
every morning i come to work and i spin
this wheel and that's what i do for the
day
whoa it's so not dramatic
[Music]
oh no oh
[Music]
yeah oh it's gonna be good old
film okay velma from scooby-doo feed
finn
okay let's get to it okay so i like
their car that they drive so i'm gonna
just have her driving a car
i'm gonna do an action shot mine's gonna
be like fast and furious wilma
so tell me about tracer so tracer
is like the poster girl for overwatch
her thing is that she's
fast so she's like pretty thin
she's petite she has a spiky
short black hair she has like these cute
little orange leggings
so velma is a nerd oh
who solves mysteries that's all you need
to know about velma
since suddenly i was like getting all
self-conscious like what's my style how
do i draw what am i what is it
why am i here on earth what does it mean
to be an artist i don't know
i'm just gonna draw and that's gonna be
my style
i feel like i'm just gonna make him
really cartoony and angry
like this drawing is really gonna evoke
get down to my swamp
i loved watching bob's burgers when i
watched it
i haven't seen it in a while though yeah
it's still going right yeah
it's a great great show it's so like
undercover funny
like they set up jokes and you're like
oh no
i'm going to sound like such an old man
but is is tracer your mane
whoa i got it
that's real i said it right right anyway
no
love that that was such a lovely little
surprise from kevin
right what's up fellow youths so linda
linda has actually a great silhouette
her hair has like this kind of mary
tyler moore thing going on um
i might be getting that wrong i guess
you can correct
people can correct me and she has no
chin but i'm gonna draw her with a chin
just because
chins makes sense to me 3d
characters versus 2d it's like
interesting
when you try to draw them exactly how
they look in 3d sometimes it might not
quite
look right because uh it's just i don't
know realistic character like shrek
i'm gonna draw finn like he's had one
too many adventures
the green reboot all these ladies are so
like voluptuous and all the dudes are
fat i feel like these women could do
better i'm just gonna say it
weren't the flintstones just caveman
version of the honeymooners though see i
don't even know what the honeymooners is
what what
i didn't even exist when it came out and
i know what the honeymooners is
so because we don't have a lot of time
are you doing anything to
simplify or change the character
no i hope the internet knows that we
only have like 20 minutes to do this
yeah they don't care yeah they want us
to suffer they're like well why didn't
you draw it like this well you know what
why don't you come here and you try to
do this there's a lot of stress involved
i kind of go between like 2d and 3d
space so i'm just adding i guess a
little more volume to this character
i think i'm going for like i love the
comic book style i decided this time to
go for even more movement even though
the character
is not designed that way we're using
this type of device called the cintiq
which is a screen that you can draw
directly on
photoshop is also just a fantastic
program
because you could do so much in it they
keep optimizing it
you know there's also like a free
alternative you can use such as [ __ ]
yeah which is very similar to photoshop
and i think it might even work with
sunsets still too
no matter how little of tools you have
you can be a great artist
it's just practice what are some tips
that you would have for people if they
wanted to learn how to draw
faster just draw faster okay that's not
a tip
the most important thing is to draw from
life i mean everybody will tell you this
and that is by far the most important
thing to learn was that good
is that good advice that was awful
advice well here's
some real advice learn some short hands
for things you know people know what
hands look like right
you don't have to make it so detailed
for people to know what a hand is right
true in animation you see a lot of
cartoons where they don't even have five
fingers
that doesn't look like a human hand
really but you know it's a hand because
you know what hands look like
keep it up kid you can do whatever you
put your mind to he's grown up
his clothes don't really fit him as well
as they used to
so his belly's sticking out so where's
jake
i don't know it's kind of a messy thing
it's either facebook just says it's
complicated
so here is how i shade my drawings i
just make a new layer
on top of the color i set the transfer
mode
to soft light and then i use 100
black to paint in the darker colors
that's a little pro tip for you there
jackie
thanks you take that home you ingest it
you use it in the future ingest it
what i do is i i draw all of my
drawing um as line art on one layer
and then i do the painting as a separate
layer underneath
so kids layers are your friend i like
mine
i think like i said it looks very
cartoony even more so than the actual
cartoon
i dig it you dig it i dig it nice all
right
confidence is key yeah all right you
ready to swap let's swap swap
oh oh dope dude what a dynamic pose
yeah i mean same for you man i like the
car
looks like a a part of her outfit oh my
god
he's so defeated what you doing in my
swamp
oh my god this is great yours is
fantastic
oh thank you oh my god he's like hit
puberty oh i love like the bags under
his head he's definitely
just like too much adventures too much
adventures
wow look at that wow this is really cool
thanks jackie this is amazing
i like this because it's different than
your normal style like i feel like your
style is usually very cheapy and very
like
very cute this is still got that like
cute appeal to it but it's way more
realistic
i like yours yours is like more than
cute i think it's more of like a comic
version
right like if there was like a comic
strip a more comedy comedy-based
scooby-doo comic strip this would be her
okay dude yours and
mine are both like they're coming
they're clashing they're coming at each
other they are coming at each other
actually
yeah i like the changes you made uh she
looks more
like mad hat like not like angry besides
the obvious improvements we made to them
i think we've taken these characters to
the next level
i think it was a lot of fun you know
like getting to really
take characters that you know and love
and
and draw it in your own style i mean i
think that's why so many people do so
much fan art
of stuff because it is fun to take these
characters and do your own take on them
this you know this was fun i wish i had
more time but i think i did what i could
and you know i wish uh you know tracer
was wearing
one shirt but
it'd be like that sometimes hey jackie
hey kevin what are we doing today
today we're spinning a wheel then we're
gonna draw what's on the wheel i pray
that i get someone that i really really
like
okay i got to spin first
yes what
yes
sailor moon anime episode baby
i don't know anything about sailor moon
she transforms and fights crime
okay cries a lot eats a lot just like me
which minion are you choosing jason
i'm choosing to draw the one with the
one eye
are you excited to draw sailor moon can
i be honest with you i'm very nervous
because
the internet loves their anime and if
you screw anything up when it comes to
anime they will let you know
so you got sonic which is a hot button
issue right now
very hot button issue i want to watch
the movie because it feels like
a embodiment of a card crash in slow
motion
should i draw a he-man with his like
pink vest or
him with his shirt off when he's like
got all the power his shirt's got to be
off man
yeah i think it's the iconic he-man look
so i don't draw on an anime style
at all i can't do it nope so i'm not
even gonna try
okay i'm going to draw a americanized
version
of sailor moon that's a good plan okay i
think
people have done that before right so
i'm not alone you're not alone
but also people love their sailor moon
oh people love their sailor moon
if you mess up even once it's gonna
really ruin everything
everyone's gonna notice when you've
watched the trailer for the first time
what was your initial reaction okay so
there's a lot of things about the design
that i feel like
could look more appealing if it looked
less realistic
yeah like the lips were a little
off-putting
feeling good about naruto i grew up
reading naruto
i love that guy i'm gonna be drawing og
naruto a young guy because he grows up
during the course of the series right
yeah
i'm gonna draw the minions the way i
think a deformed creature made by a
super villain should look i'm gonna draw
a very buff the buffest he-man
the world has ever seen i'm sticking
relatively close to
the original because i do naturally draw
stuff pretty cartoony
but uh yeah i think i'll add you know
make his eyes a little bigger make him a
little
cuter so the real minion just looks like
a pill
a pill with an eye wearing like trousers
so i'm gonna do a monstrosity version
of that naruto is constructed like a
real boy
you know he's not cartoony well
obviously like it's like cartoon
it's anime i'm gonna go for a more
exaggerated
he-man look his original construction i
don't know man
if you go to like a life drawing class
and just give the dude some like
blonde fryer boy hair it's kind of what
you get with
with he-man here's what i know about
sailor moon she
changes into sailor moon kind of like
how
diana prince changes into wonder woman
right they like spin around
and there's like magic and then she
becomes and i know that she's part of
like a girl
force yes of like five or six
other fighters are they all also
nautical
based nautical based yeah because she's
a sailor oh
i i don't know she's not actually a
sailor
no internet i am so sorry goofy
is very lanky really a
real tall guy but he's he's got like a
nice kind of elasticity to him because
he's a
he's a comical character you know i
think i really want to keep that
intact might just add a little bit of
geometry
to like his back and his body and stuff
here's a little tip for you kids
if you are drawing a face and you want
to know if your proportions are correct
i highly recommend taking your drawing
and flipping it horizontally as i just
did yes and now i can see
that boy her eye is in the wrong place
yeah so do you think you're gonna you're
gonna want sonic the movie though
we'll see honestly i'm interested to see
how they alter it because they are gonna
change his character design
brent did you watch he-man growing up
absolutely not i don't think they were
even doing like reruns
in the 90s slash 2000s my naruto is
definitely a fan art naruto
i'm just drawing him as i would draw
anybody else in my style oh he has like
conan the barbarian boots okay he's
basically
kona and the barbarian for kids oh yeah
i guess so i guess that's they're being
inspired by that stuff a lot
yeah and inspired with quotes i think
one of my favorite parts of sailor moon
is that it's got lots of fun expressions
oh yeah yeah i don't know if you've seen
any of them ever
but it's not that it goes off model but
you know how an anime they often do like
oh right like when they get really
excited they suddenly turn into chibi
yeah yeah stuff like that i think sailor
moon does it best
i don't know if if this even has the
essence of sonic
it's it's sonic adjacent okay so i just
noticed that she has a
forehead band that i did not put in my
drawing and so
the internet would be very upset if i
didn't so
i gotta put it in real quick you almost
died so this is the best part about
he-man the way i'm
most familiar with him is that four
non-blondes meme jason do you know what
i'm talking about
i don't remember that i don't know the
meme do you know oh no i do when they're
dancing
in the bar yeah yeah yeah yeah and they
like cut together
just like a couple of frames of he-man
like doing like a little twist and it
looks like he's dancing that's about as
good as the internet got all right home
stretch jackie how you feeling
feeling good feeling ready are you ready
i'm getting close i think this is the
best i can do you know
i'm done this is sonic i'm so excited to
see
you done done done i think my minion's
done
all right i do not know what i was
thinking with the pose in this one
it's a little weird i think my drawings
are really reminiscent of what i
grew up drawing drew a lot of spider-man
and like when i think of
characters they all have like gangly
moving limbs i think i did good i think
he looks cool
i took a different approach and sort of
emphasized the
muscular aspect of the character i think
i am very successful at making people
upset i'm sorry everybody
i think i did okay it is not anime at
all nothing wrong with that nothing
wrong
it's fan art and for what it is i think
i'm pretty proud of it you know what
that's all that matters
oh wow oh my god jason i think the
minion brought out
some of the best in you oh so
it's so joyful who didn't know what i
was expecting
yeah yeah all right it really isn't
anime
but it really is kevin's drawing thank
you i like it
thank you if sailor moon was on ice in
new york
this is the girl that would play her
what kira did is to make him
much more fun and bouncy you can almost
see what dance he's going to do next
he-man is so ridiculous i love that his
drawing embraces that like he looks
impossibly muscular you made him a lot
cuter there's a lot more appeal to him
you know his his original character is
very it's very realistic
i feel like this naruto has a lot more
fun the reference image you have right
now that's an angry naruto is he angry
most of the time
no he's very goofy naruto is a goofy guy
i think you really captured the essence
of how radical he is
the hair got it it's iconic we did some
creepy
science experiments to this minion and
created a monster
although he's still got some of that
like minion appeal
this would be like an anime like manga
adaptation yeah
of despicable me i think you can try to
emulate
a particular style and you can learn a
lot from doing that yeah but at the end
of the day
when you draw something in your own
style that
translation of it is something that's
totally valuable yeah that's totally
you having your own style and you know
as you
draw and as you learn that style
will come to you that's for all you
young artists out there
trying to find yourself i believe in you
draw more naruto
he's a cool guy what jackie said all
right kevin
hey jackie we're doing something a
little different today guys
today we are drawing character mashup
from the wheel
we're gonna spin the wheel twice and
whatever two characters we get we gotta
mash em up oh god i'm scared oh
boy oh sonic sonic sonic that's a solid
solid character
and mario i just have to technically
take one of these characters and make
like a fan hedgehog
who are you gonna get who's kevin gonna
get no face from spirited away
all right no face and
right in the middle right on the edge
i'm gonna make you do kermit
kermit no face sounds horrifying
oh no johnny bravo uncle johnny bro
and johnny bravo oh my god
oh oh woody oh dang i thought it was
gonna be like sailor moon
and this is great johnny bravo
oh oh god now
and yes
oh shrekloff
jerry jerry okay you got a mouse
garfield garfield okay okay so
let's get started let's do
[Music]
i'm gonna it the hell out of these
characters that's weird don't do that i
don't think i need to use reference
because like kermit's like literally
just like
you know just like do you remember what
kermit looks like i kind of do yeah the
shrek snowman or ogre olaf i don't i
think ogre olaf
is this gonna be a grotesque one for you
you know what it might be
because i'm like afraid because this is
just a cat and a mouse should i draw
kermit
drinking the tea oh yes yeah all right
oh of course
why did you even ask and it's obviously
a yes you got to do the meme
you gotta do the meme what did you
decide to go with uh shrek snowman
shrek snapchat i think it's kind of the
vibe i want to go for did you like
frozen
jason how do you feel about it i did not
like frozen but
i also like have a one and a half year
old
and it's like maybe i will start to like
froze
you gotta be ready for that frozen two
is coming
so which do you prefer sonic or mario
i think mario i've played more mario
games this is going weird
it's supposed to go weird it's like
strange
i don't really know if what we're doing
is
moral it is absolutely not my process as
most people are probably noticing is a
little bit different than
i think a lot of what other people have
done i use a lot of shapes
i use a lot of forms i work from values
a lot so i like to work from values
because it gets me a little bit faster
but it is very hard i'm not going to
make it sound like oh yeah i just
painted values you guys will all be all
right like it takes a lot of work it
takes a lot of effort to get good at it
like i spend years getting good at it
like what process do you prefer
but i think for this one i mainly am
starting from sketching
i'm just like okay i'm trying to feel
the gesture and i'm trying to feel
um like how the pose gonna be okay this
is going to be a very simple drawing
is it yeah because no face's body is
just black
why do you love shrek so much brent you
actually talk about them a lot i do talk
about shrek a lot it's just something
it's half ironic half genuine love for
this character
i just love the the artistic direction
dreamworks decided to take with these
characters
like they weren't really sure how to do
cgi back in the early 2000s
all these creepily realistic faces i
love kermit the frog
do you love kermit the frog i do what do
you love most about kermit the frog he's
just so
good-natured and you're gonna say he's
so good-looking he's just a
handsome young man he's just the most
handsome frog i know
he's just trying the best he can and
everyone around him
is an idiot or a weirdo
once you watch the muppets he's the
straight man he's the one who's holding
it together
wait did he have a short sleeve shirt
johnny bravo what is your reference yes
um he has like a black mask like
masculine shirt that's
super muscle type like a clubber shirt
right like he's going to the club
uh yeah he definitely skipped leg bay
though that was a thing
right like he definitely skipped leg day
dang it i wish i did better
you feel self-consciously get no don't
let it don't let the
rgb not get too i will try my best until
zero seconds jason you gotta level with
me here you're gonna be ruining some
childhoods with this one
oh yes it's not even a question
i'm gonna try to bring in some of that
dreamworks detail
because the difference between
dreamworks and
disney is a pretty stark divide
between their approaches to character
design i think the key here is to just
lean into
what an abomination just the concept of
these
mashups is yeah you know like get a
cronenberg monster out of this thing
like oh my god that's like my dream this
is weird
i don't like this get weird with it
jackie i don't know what to do with his
other hand
what are you doing i'm trying to
remodeling do you want me to model it so
you can see
no i don't need your pity
no oh it's me
sonic uh i went to um ai
we had a teacher who once like told a
student just like looked at her in their
faces like you'll never make it in this
industry
ever really quit now oh my god i'm not
like even trigger coding like i'm
telling you
he just straight up told her like don't
chase your dreams
quit life and get out of my room and
really like
whoa the reality is like the industry's
not like that you know people
don't like talk to you that way they
they will hire you if they feel like
you're qualified
and if you're not you just gotta you
just gotta work towards that it's really
that simple
stay positive guys keep keep drawing
yeah draw every day
how how are you doing with yours i feel
like it's coming together
it's the creepier the better you know
yeah i went too ambitious but i really
like it
so i'm gonna i'm gonna go with it well
this is weird
this is a very strange thing i'm drawing
is it yep
how so it just looks like kermit
wearing a black robe sipping tea there
is a meme like that isn't there
like kermit like talking to himself with
the
black robot oh yeah that's what you're
drawing i don't even think about that oh
should i do a
double a triple mash up a triple magic
two kermit memes
and a spirited away character why not
it's not like we're running out of time
at all
okay you know you're right oh
but can you do it i'm going to try okay
come on
hurry hurry all right just five minutes
wow
get on to some color moment of truth
jason green snow or just gross
gross brown snow i want green snow green
snow all right we're doing it
oh yeah he wants you out of his swamp
because he is the swamp
i am the swamp my shrek he's a tragic
character you know
he's not long for this world what does
um
what do you say like don't do the sky no
that's buzz lightyear right
wait like reach for the sky right reach
for the sky wait
is that woody yeah that is i love toy
story
like so much wasn't that great though in
that movie where
woody like turns his head you know like
360
like when that moment where like uh sid
was gonna
set them up fire i love that moment i
remember watching that as a kid and
being like
oh dude dope 30 seconds jackie 30
seconds i believe in you
all right home stretch and then you know
fast like sonic excuse me i need to
focus and you are not helping at all
all right olaf olaf shrek there you go
all right i'm as done as i'll ever be
for now all right
okay
[Music]
i think i'm i'm good with this yeah
how'd you think you did brent well i
think i really captured the spirit of
what it means to mash up two characters
into an ugly abomination
it just looks like i neither know what
sonic or
mario looks like i feel good about mine
but i
i think i could have pushed it more mine
looks like
i took a kermit
and repainted him and put him in a giant
black sock
huh wow
oh god wow
oh this is so good oh i hate you this is
so good oh i'm gonna quit art
oh my god this is incred i think you
destroyed more childhoods than i did i
don't know if that's true
looks like kermit died he became the new
grim reaper
and this is him after a lovely day of
taking people's souls
he's like maybe going to heaven you may
be going to hell that's not my concern
that's what this is it's very spooky
this is actually what i should have done
no your narrative is spot on
like it has so much good character in it
uh i think yours is
just you're just too nice dude it looks
like he's eaten multiple
multiple jerry's in there what the if it
had more time there'd be vomit
jason you're the childhood slayer i'm
gonna say that
yours is really imaginative is it you
know what yours is a great mashup so
here's the thing don't be so hard on
yourself
huh this matchup is incredible i think
like i think yours was very successful
okay yeah i appreciate it i think yours
is very successful mashing up characters
on the spot is very hard yeah you gotta
think of
a lot of things and you gotta design it
very quickly
mashups is a genuine strategy
for design yeah like i think like people
don't realize it
a lot of like their favorite tv shows
movies video games are a mashup of some
some sort i agree i think like mashing
up stuff is also a great
way to get out of your bubble so i think
it's like a great
thing for people to try get out of here
kevin i don't want to see you anymore
see you tomorrow oh god be sure to stick
around to the end of the video to find
out how you can enter for a chance to
win this
wacom intuos tablet courtesy of our good
friends at wacom
there are two free creative programs
that come with this wow
right you don't even have to spend three
million dollars on
adobe photoshop let's face it software
is expensive software is expensive and
you know what else is expensive
what hot dogs
all right are hot dogs expensive yeah
sure
hey i'm kevin hey i'm jackie and today
we're going to mash up characters from
the wheel
what's it going to be jackie oh who
knows could it be
daffy duck and
[Music]
skeletor that's so odd
dora the explorer let's see who dora's
going to be matched up with
rocco it looks like you'll be drawing
taco the explorer
i'm scared porky pig
pork pig and
jaffy duck okay porky pig and daffy duck
okay whoa that's gonna be so fun you
should go there again it's okay
i got carp garfield and
[Music]
woody wow garfield
that's kind of cute yeah okay
ready second sprint
that's actually so cute oh here we go
wonder woman wonder woman okay
respectable choice
and spongebob
that's gonna look great
okay all right do you believe in
yourself i do believe myself do you
believe in me
why'd you have to pause okay
i have a vision
he has no pants i don't remember any of
this porky has no pants
they're both not wearing pants so here's
my question do i do
spongebob cosplaying as wonder woman or
do i do
wonder woman spongy
[Music]
don't do wonder i don't want to see that
you don't want to see that so which
character are you concentrating on more
i think i'm going to give it like
rocco's
wallaby body but like dora's
[Music]
like hair and stuff you know i'll credit
garfield calvin and hopped into the far
side for teaching me how to read english
that's cute like i learned a lot of
things reading comics my
my parents bought me a lot of
educational comics even
when i was in korea like there was a
whole like comic series that that's
about like different cultures
but also the the addition of garfield
that i had came with like a little like
flip book
as part of the book so like when you
flipped you can see garfield
like moving and then another side was it
was odie that was also like another way
to like
get me excited about animation so jackie
what is your strategy here
should i make daffy duck buff or you
could do
daffy duck with a skeleton face no wow
no no no no no that's just a terrible
idea
what makes you think skeletor is a
skeleton because he has a skeleton face
no are you not familiar with who
skeletor is he doesn't have a skeleton
face
he literally does that's why he's called
skeletal no his name is called skeletor
because he's doing it again
you're drawing me in jackie of course
in a game of random chance with a wheel
you happen to get a simpson's character
obviously i'm not going to draw
marge the way she actually looks i
wanted to go for the betty boop pose
skeletor's pretty cool though i like the
minimal amount of clothes he's wearing
he knows what he's about he's super buff
yeah i mean if i was this buff i would
also avoid
wearing as much clothes as possible
because who wouldn't want to see
sexy blue biceps right yeah
i mean i'd be really self-conscious that
i don't have a
i don't have skin on my face well or i
think he's compensating
i'm literally going for monstrosity
i'm actually having a lot of fun drawing
this cowboy garfield cowboy garfield
that's essentially what i'm drawing so
when was daffy duck
invented invented yeah when did thomas
edison
sit down and invent daffy dub
uh i'm going to say in
the 1930s 1930s yeah i was alive then
no you weren't like i'm trying to
imagine what
the voice of fusion of daffy duck and
porky pig is like
okay
it's like lisping also like really like
crazy
[Music]
if anybody out there has the vocal
talent to fuse the voices
of daffy duck and porky pig please
please do please respond what i will say
though is rocco and dora
have similar like they're both pretty
small stout characters
so similar proportions similar
proportions
well betty boop has a little more
anatomy than marge
yeah so just trying to find a happy
medium i love skeletor's
cute nails yeah he does have uh
nice little nails he has cute nails on
it which is a little cuddy type
yeah it's very cute he like takes care
of his nails it's
and he paints them black he's really
compensating for that no face thing he
really
is i'm taking like porky's nose i'm
taking daffy's beak
throwing in a little bit hey june in
there me
yeah sorry you had to find out like that
is skeletor like really evil or is he
like cartoon evil is he just
misunderstood
he's definitely bumbling i will i'll
give you that he's a dum-dum
he's not the greatest villain his
schemes always backfire but it's mostly
due to his incompetent henchmen
at a certain point it's like why are you
getting the worst henchmen
to do that job you know times are tough
times are tough good health is hard to
find
not a lot of uh henchmen around these
days especially henchmen with henchmen
degrees
yep the henchman degree does not pay
what it used to yeah
have you actually ever met matt greening
i've met him a couple of times how was
he
he's super friendly always willing to
talk all around nice guy
that must be so surreal to just be him
all right boom done how'd you do
i think i did a good job yeah i think it
it looks like a grim reaper
undead buff daffy duck
this is the thing you see when you die
is he cute he's cute yeah i would swipe
right on him on tinder
so how do you think he did i think he
did pretty good it's just rocco indoors
how about you how do you think you did i
mean that's how i feel it's like betty
boop trying to be marge
but i mean they're the best that i could
and i accept that
i think this is this is pretty close to
what i have in my head
cute switcheroo you're gonna ask me how
i did on mine
no okay let's switch
man yours is so cute oh dude i love this
oh my gosh she's adorable oh i love her
like
garter or like whatever it's called this
is totally
rocco and a hollering costume
i want this monster to be in real life
and i'm coming from its womb
oh wow oh
why did you draw it at an up angle kevin
power
power stance it looks more like a
bdsm thing fun fact wonder woman was
actually created
as a bdsm character the creator of
wonder woman
i want to say his name is william
marston something he was actually like a
bdsm
cartoonist this is not a fun fact
this is more of a disturbing fact i
think you primarily use like betty
boop's body
and then flourishes of marge within the
colors
the accessories i think like the eyes
yeah like a nice mix of betty roop and
marge in the eyes
i don't think there's a part that she
didn't use all
all parts of the creatures are
represented in this drawing
plus extra there's a dash of shrek
so yours is a delight it's a delight yes
i think it's a great combination of the
two characters ah
i like how you kept skeletor's buff body
but gave him a duck face one one
suggestion i would have given you is for
his staff
you should have put a fossilized
duckhead
well i i made a bird it's a bird but
like
you know what i mean like the head of
his enemies oh like
bugs bunny bugs bunny head on a steak
that's what daffy duck would that's what
daphne tour would want
duck a tour scale of duck would want i
really love what hayden has done here i
know my garf
i know my garf hey jun and like let me
tell you
you got him you got him good i think
this is actually like a really good
exercise for if you have like art block
or something right just
take two cartoon characters and mash
them together and see what you get
yeah and sometimes you can even get
something completely different and a
whole new character
out of those things i i thoroughly
enjoyed this this is what art is about
you take old ideas you make them new you
know what i will
i will continue to mash up characters
because i think it's a fun way to
stretch your character design
muscles like the muscles on your
duckator daffatore
skele duck skeledoc so if you want to
enter for a chance to win this wacom
intuos tablet all you have to do is go
to buzzfeed comics instagram that's at
comics on instagram
find this post and follow the
instructions in the description
best of luck to you thank you blue apron
for the pistachio wacom
tablet no it is first of all it's not
blue apron it's sponsoring us it is
welcome
thank you dollar shave club for the
welcome tablets
that is quite enough hi i'm stephanie
hey i'm kira
and today we are drawing characters that
we have never seen before
based on each other's descriptions
do i trust you i don't trust me trusting
me not trusting me i chose something
incredibly obscure
but also simple okay i feel like mine is
simple in construction
and it's what's gonna be interesting is
how the details come in
but first be sure to stick around to the
end of the video to find out how you can
enter for a chance to win this wacom
intuos tablet for all of your digital
drawing needs
courtesy we are good friends at welcome
did you know that your hair and nails
continue to grow
after you die how is that relevant
[Music]
[Applause]
all right so what character am i drawing
today all right so for you i chose
junkrat from overwatch no idea who that
is
yeah he's a junkie boy what are you
making me draw i'm making you draw a
comic book character from
my era the 1700s stop it
by the name of spawn oh so stephanie
what have you chosen for me to draw
you are going to be drawing raz rasputin
from psychonauts so what am i going to
be drawing so i chose
the most obscure thing ever i chose roo
from pero pero sparkles that means
nothing to me
you are drawing shin chan
shin chan shin classic shin chan my boy
shin chance
who the hell is jin chan so am i drawing
today i have a very special pokemon for
you today cody his name is garbador
the garbage pokemon garbage in concept
and design so give me an overall
description of junkrat so he's like a
human
yeah he's an australian dude he's just
like laffy and giggly he loves
destruction
okay so he's chaotic evil he's chaotic
he's not evil he's like chaotic
neutral give me like an overall
description so he's shirtless he's got
some
pants on he's like the joker he well he
but he's not
clean like the joker oh okay junkrat is
like
he's wacky is he wild and wacky he's
wild and wacky with overwatch
junkrat uses grenades and stuff it's
like a grenade launcher
his ultimate move is that he has this
tire
it rolls around and it explodes okay oh
two more things
i feel like i have to tell you his hair
is on fire seriously
kind of and he is missing two limbs let
me give you an overall description of
spawn so you can start drawing okay so
we're gonna
be drawing at the same time yep it's
gonna break your brain oh my brain is
already
not really fully completed okay so give
me a general description of rasputin
yeah so he's human his overall
construction
big head small body long limbs
very angular in his design in the game
he's what they call
a psychonauts so he's going to summer
camp to learn
how to be a psychonaut and basically
infiltrate people's minds
all right give me somewhere to start
with this okay well first of all just so
you know
he's like two heads tall so he's a very
small person yeah he's squat
it's a child and his head is like oh man
it's kind of like a bee i'm sure
somebody there's like hardcore shin chan
fans out there screaming like his head's
the classic b
shape or something you know whatever
they do oh you know it's that bit that
that like being like
cartoon network character head that like
clarence and everybody has oh
oh i know what you're talking about yes
the cartoon network face what does roo
look like okay so you're gonna think of
it's like an
alien teddy bear and the one thing that
i will give you
is the eyes look like they have the
entire universe in them it's like a
galaxy
eye colorful care beary
really cute kind of like pokemon
anime-ish
a spawn is if venom and
superman went to like a goth party
this is getting more confusing for me
because i'm imagining
a buff goth kid i mean if you want to go
into a story he's
undead and he gets his powers from a
deal that he made with the devil
oh my god why did he do that did he die
at one point he did
and he went to hell yep he used to be a
mercenary killed people for money
and so he went to hell and he made a
deal with the devil because he wanted to
see his wife one more time the devil
being the devil gave him like
demonic superpowers put him back on the
earth
but then wiped his memory so he didn't
know who his wife was
oh so that sucks yeah so here's garbador
for you he's an amorphous blob pokemon
great so really no not too much defining
he's sort of just a mound so his
pre-evolved form is a garbage bag
and as he evolved it looks like the bag
just kind of busts open from the bottom
like he got too fat with stuff and so
now like there's the top of his mound is
like a bag that's been split open
so he's like a pyramid shape blobby
pyramid what is sparkle sparkle
peripera woohoo whatever
it is so pero power sparkles it's um
made by this indie artist in japan and
it's used for a lot of fashion and
uh comics merchandise it's just kind of
like a like a mascot character sort of
thing
i feel like it's probably one of those
things that i've seen like a dozen times
but have never actually
like put a face or name to is it like in
the kind of
sanrio realm of character for sure
very sanrio does he have any motives
this guy what do you mean
you know how the motive of spider-man is
a spider and superman is an s
he doesn't really on his chest he has a
swath of a different color
it's like a logo or is it you know what
don't tell me make your choice
i will draw what i think spawn's logo
would be
follow your heart and it's a skull cause
gods
love human anatomy
i don't know what he wears but i'm gonna
try my best
i can give you some basic description so
he has like a aviator helmet with uh
some goggles i remember that okay
i mean his basic outfit is like a
sweater a jacket
and pants um he has gloves too does this
character wear anything or
she just nope naked
okay i still don't have much to work
with with your guy he's a pretty simple
character
describe as much as you can as quickly
as possible he's got a red sweater
his arms taper to like really thin
wrists same thing with the legs legs
just taper to like tiny
little kind of pointy feet and he's got
yellow shorts white socks on
does junkrat is he wearing shoes yes
he's wearing shoes is he wearing like
boots oh
you know what one of his legs is like a
peg leg
okay like it is is that one of his one
of his missing limbs is
one of his legs is a peg leg but they're
not gone gone he's replaced them this is
the future
right so you're a storyboard revisionist
on muppet babies which is adorable
um so do you feel like the character
that i've given you to draw is kind of
in that wheelhouse
definitely like you know we've got
fozzie bear on that show baby fuzzy
and you know he's super those kind of
anime should be proportions
same with all the other characters
they're all very like two to three heads
tall
and and big limbs and everything like
that so like i've
probably been drawing a character like
this
in some regard for the last nine months
that i've been there
so once you've got his body down i'll go
into describing his horrendous looking
hands
oh he has hands so one of them is kind
of coming out of like the bottom
of his body his right hand and then his
other one it's just like the same thing
but it's like
near where his shoulder you would
imagine it would be in terms of bogs
they're kind of loopy bowie boggs is an
account the land of bogs that i
work on at buzzfeed one of them has
these great arms for squeezing things
so we're trying to reference things that
we're more familiar with
so since we both work in animation do
you use a wacom tablet
i do yeah actually um we use uh cintiqs
at work and then i have a cintiq at home
that i
brilliance animation on so i've been
using yeah like wacom since
i was maybe like 11 or 12. like my dad
wanted to like
get me in the digital art game pretty
early
yeah i also have um a cintiq here at
work
and at home and yeah i started really
young with
a like an intros or something and as
soon as i went onto cintiq i was like i
can't ever go back
it feels so good to just draw like on
the screen can i give you just one word
and you interpret it however you want i
mean i've already committed to this
goth kid look maybe are you ready i'm
ready
spikes spikes does he have spiky
knuckles
you interpret that however you want okay
i think spikes jackie
i'm gonna give him spikes on his head oh
you said there's nothing on his head
there's nothing on his head
i've already drawn them hopefully
they're just going to be there and the
thing about drawing digitally is there's
no way to erase
no there's no way i've never if there is
a way can someone please let me know
let us know in the comments oh no i'm
going to tell you something about
garbador no about the character i'm
drawing
about as you gave me the head details i
think i
might know this character i think it's
coming to me so if you ever get amnesia
and we need to revive your memory we
just make you draw it you'll remember
things that you've seen before
yeah is there anything that this little
character is supposed to
i will say they have a tail that's like
got a big poof ball of these i didn't
plan for a tail
no oh you know what he has very very
stubby
feet at the bottom that are just made of
the garbage they're like that purple
she's like grimace yeah he's basically a
garbage grimace so
i think i just drew venom and goth
clothes
you're not far off i don't like spawn
listen
if you were a dude like me in the 90s
you were all about spawn it's a good
thing i'm a woman like me in the
2010s and i love instead
dirty pyromaniacs oh i didn't make him
dirty
come on i didn't have time to make him
dirty oh he's so
filthy he probably looks like a
gentleman
yeah how do you think you did cody this
is one of the most
uh disgusting things i've drawn in a
long time
yeah probably the grosser the better
this character is very cute
i think from what i'm remembering
vaguely in my head of this character
if i do know it i think this is accurate
but
it was only because you gave me such
good description how do you think you
did
i think i did okay he looks like
like a little animal crossing character
but i don't know he's
cute how do you think you did i mean i
heard teddy bear and i just like
this is what i snapped to so i think
it's uh
as close as i could get it without
seeing
[Applause]
oh no you kind of did it you did
oh my gosh this is passable champagne
the disgusting blob pokemon
it turns out he can be described
effectively huh okay
this is not spawn but i can see how you
got here from my description
this looks like aquaman cosplaying
junkrat
why'd you give him like an earring cause
he's like he's like a crazy
guy are crazy dudes yeah he's going
to be a little wacky watch this
oh i love him yours is such a
no like you definitely channeled it
really yeah
this is here ridiculously cute like
yours is very cute
you definitely made him a uh a much more
optimistic
character than anything he said he does
like he's just a kind of angsty boy
you know he's a bit he's a bit
aggressive okay let's switch back
okay
[Applause]
oh oh you didn't mention like the
like blob of of stuff on her head that's
so
cute oh
okay i get it he's more shaped he's like
a picasso painting
it's funny that you even knew to
describe this as
garbage because without knowing his name
like i didn't even i don't even read
that
as like a trash bag really this is just
confusing looking you know i did well
jackie
no okay no i did i you did
okay kevin you got much closer
than i did it looks you know again if
you squid it's junkrat and you were kind
enough to give him a bag for all his
stuff
you know the original designers didn't
do that oh man okay yeah i got like
some stuff right like the hair i just
made that up i'm amazed that i like kind
of got the color
he has a striped shirt which i sort of
predicted
mine is definitely like baby version i
feel like my
my version is like if you took the
design and made it western
yeah this guy looks way more angry this
guy just kind of looks like his mom told
him he couldn't go to the concert alone
oh come on mom mom everybody else is
going i'm the only one who can't grow
but i'm spawning mom
mom i'm spawn i have demonic powers i
can and will send you to hell
if i had to pick a person to describe
things to me we work together so much
that i think you're probably the right
person to describe
our cartoon i've never heard of to me so
it was pretty easy
i guess we have more of a shorthand that
we can sort of draw on
like i think referencing other
characters is very important
it was kind of cool to interpret what i
was told and not just like
just try to fill in the blanks yourself
there's a nice like creative flow that
came from that this was really fun i
really like doing it so the fact that i
got closer than i thought that i did
i will say is a compliment to your
descriptive abilities
and you know what me getting really far
off is an insult
to you okay giveaway time if you want to
enter for a chance to win this wacom
intuos s
tablet all you have to do is go to
buzzfeed comics
instagram that's at comics on instagram
find this post
and follow the instructions in the
description best of luck to you
can i get some pogs in the comment for
this giveaway
from star wars from star wars yep
completely i don't know
hi i'm cody hi i'm heijun today we're
going to be drawing
whatever the internet wants us to yeah
and i'll add horns
and appendages to all of it i'm scared
this is a replay of a live stream so if
you hear a disembodied
phantom voice it's our moderator matt is
our ghost moderator
he floats and it's very impressive let's
start with a ufo
piloted by a cow i'm guessing people are
still feeling
the storming area 51 memes bella jane
suggests a young child who is rocking a
dragon costume
that's nice i like one suggestion that
was just
pizza man pizza man i think we got a
pizza man
what else are we gonna do i'm feeling
the dragon kid though ooh
i like i would personally like to see
um a cat doing pottery okay
you wanna do that or a unicorn playing
the piano
unicorn i want to draw a unicorn what
about a cat
doing pottery with a unicorn like in
that scene from ghosts
i'm trying to think like ghosts
shout out to louise kiwi for the pizza
man
suggestion shout out to louise what is
your plan for pizza man brent
jason i all will be revealed
it's been a while since you've been on
draw off nick it has been a while does
it feel
uh it feels like i never left just want
to give a quick shout out to crazy doc
thank you for the suggestion of the cat
doing pottery
unicorns and cats are very popular i
mean
why not you know i forgot what cavs look
like so i'm going to draw
a far side cow if anybody knows that
comic reference kudos to you i have a
19 month old little child and he is
awesome
maybe i'll buy him a dragon costume
maybe i'll make him a dragon costume
and we already have our first edition uh
the cow
is joined by peppa pig
is that a specific pig it's it's a
beloved children's pick
it's the biggest copyrighted we can
can't do it okay so
should we do salt pig uh mustard pig
oh yeah okay we're drawing mustard pig
unicorn's got to be majestic
and by majestic i mean i don't know how
to draw a horse
just kind of roughing out like rough
placement
helps me to kind of see what's sort of
because in my head right now it's like i
sort of have like a fuzzy idea of what i
want to draw
it's not really clear enough some people
they're just like boom they know exactly
what they want to draw and they're just
like
but for me it's sort of like a like a
like an exploration
honestly that's it forever like even
when you become a professional artist
you're always just going to be like i
have no idea what i'm doing
yeah pretty much you never will june did
you
grow up wanting to be an animator i
did actually somewhere in my parents
apartment in korea
are dusty old post-it notes full of
animated stick figures doing violent
things because
that's apparently what you animate when
you first animate things the overall
consensus
in the chat not to give anything away
for jason is
is that the pizza man legs
are making them feel some type of way
pizza man is available for bachelorette
parties
you can book now oh my god i gotta give
this
like a beautiful just
mane of hair i love that my unicorn
looks more like a cow
i think i don't even know
i love chubby bunny a quick
suggestion take it or leave it maria d
maria has been trying to get a mullet on
everything today
and thinks that pizza man pizza man's
gonna have a mullet
okay you've got your mullet here we go
so that's what we do here at draw up
live we make dreams come true
you know i gotta say i don't think i've
drawn a mullet just about
ever but we're gonna make this happen
it's gonna be a cheesy
cheese mullet do we have anything else
on the cow like
i need to know more about this is he
happy driving it is he being held
hostage by the pig
is the cow taking the pig to the
hospital and the pig's like bleeding out
from a laser wound
could you come up with a backstory for
my little unicorn i'm drawing
if that's okay you guys you've birthed
this creature
i need to know where he comes from bbgr
suggests that she
just broke up with her boyfriend and is
writing a song about it
obviously she's pretty happy about it i
got a good suggestion
from uh jason brown the cow
has graduated top of his class at mit
so this is the cow's thesis very
specific
pastel world says pizza man was an
olympic ice skater who turned into a
crime-fighting
mullet rocking vigilante who destroys
enemies with pepperoni
but the pepperoni frisbee of destruction
i like the idea that he just sort of
peels off pepperonis from his body and
throws them at his enemies
mac aid suggests that the pig
is the significant other i'm ruminating
on this new relationship
i just want to shout out a lot of these
backstories for the unicorns
are so well thought out and touching
if i read them i might cry oh my god
yeah
so uh language is very insistent on a
pink cow a pink cow i can make that
happen we can make those dreams come
true another question from marsha
marshall what's your question how do you
draw human body parts so well
oh well thanks uh just hitting your head
against the wall for
like a decade i'd say just trying
every freaking day to draw feet and
being really bad at it for most of the
time
and then you know one day you'll wake up
and you'll be like oh i get it
i get how feet work drawing things
really fast
i i've realized um
helps because you learn to get like the
way things flow
i think this is probably a post
graduation celebration they are going to
party they're they're drunk farm animals
i like to think that maybe this cow is
the designated driver
and the pig is drunk on mustard when
you're laughing at your own drawing
that's usually good
i think oh my god i got to get to color
though i want to put
so much pink on this no don't make
everything pink that's that's not how
definitely how this works
oh works for me actually no pizza man
needs
beautiful eyes jessica jones says i've
really been staring at pizza man's legs
for 17 minutes
here i'll help you out with that there
you go
[Music]
yeah this is about to be real messy
y'all
this uh gotta get some good leg shots in
here
there we go hey june how you feeling
about your uh
your party animals i'm looking at the
colors right now i feel if
it feels like it belongs in the rugrats
blanchies says
i want to see some grease on pizza man
he's actually
he's just he's sort of done getting
greased and now there's just like a pool
of grease
underneath him where he has been
dripping
all day oh my god i'm so ashamed of
myself i drew a drawing
recently and i drew a character's hand
backwards
oh that's that's like i'm so dumb oh
people do that all the time it's okay
because you get you get into a drawing
and you forget you're just like oh
just drawing and then you're like oh
everything about this is wrong like if i
took this drawing and
flipped it which is by the way a great
thing you can do when you're drawing is
draw and then flip the drawing like if i
took this and reversed it i probably
would just be like
i see all sorts of problems i'm really
excited for what you're drawing i think
i'm the one who draws through something
this is very strange i gotta say i took
this a little far
yeah you guys are kind of drawing each
other's stuff
yeah we're going to kind of switch
places here yeah what is
what a strange turn of events got to do
a
an otherworldly unicorn glow because
unicorn is sort of you know a ghost
unicorns are gone what are you talking
about
it's it's over put your pants down i'm
done
all right pizza man is done this is as
gross as he's ever gonna look
i can keep going definitely but i think
i can stop here as well
yeah so how do you think you did cody if
i saw this
out of context like on my instagram feed
i wouldn't know what to make of it and i
would just like
keep scrolling i think i i also feel
those sentiments
i drew now looking at it what looks like
a
cow horse unicorn holding a pot with the
cat
i like it it's weird
[Music]
oh my god this is really good this is so
wholesome
wow i love it yours is amazing omg yours
just adorable
kyra is so good at drawing cute stuff
i like the storytelling involved with
this like graduated married thing he
looks like he's really about this job
he's just like yo
i'm about to do a performance don't get
in the splash zone yeah
i really love that mustard pig is just a
regular pig
mustard color i i love this the
disembrace that your characters are in
there's palpable tension and
you hope that the the cow will land the
ufo safely you got the majestic
thank you feeling of a unicorn but you
did too yours is so good
like it's hilarious we have definitely
this is character development jason
drawing with the internet suggests
is really fun and i want to do it more i
like this because
i don't have to stick to a character
design that i'm
like trying to remember which is the
normal format of the show
thanks for these sassy farm animals yes
thank you very much
see everyone drawing's awesome just
don't stop drawing okay hey i'm jackie
hey i'm kevin
and today we're going to be drawing
whatever the internet tells us so this
is a replay of a previously recorded
live stream
the chat of the live stream will be
telling us what to draw as embodied by
the voice of our producer
matt matt we're gonna start throwing
suggestions at you
okay if something gravity if you use
gravity or something
if something grabbeth thy attention
drop it draw with it that trough
oh i should be a town crier you should
lexi
bora don't know how to pronounce it
dinosaurs in burlesque outfits
uh cat on a board skateboarding
on an alligator not sure how that one
works we got
a teenager learning to use an element of
your choosing
this is just avatar that's the long line
of avatar the last airbender that they
brought in
jackie as a cat you take that back
whoever said that
jackie as a squirrel you take that back
we got a reverse centaur a reverse
center so like horse top
human person bottom a cthulhu working
his summer job
katsulu working a summer job i'm gonna
look up what cthulhu looks like
are you gonna do that yeah i think you
could do that really cute the thing was
kind of scary i'm gonna draw this i'm
gonna draw you you're gonna draw a
cthulu
at a summer job and working a summer job
okay
what job should catholic have i was
thinking uh just a simple
cashier oh kevin as a squirrel kevin as
a squirrel now that's a suggestion i can
get behind
all right i'll do me as a squirrel ooh a
little shade in the chat barbara b says
kevin will do him
anyways oh wow wait a minute barbara v
that's my mom mom
is that really your that's my mom mom
what the hell
i guarantee you barbara v is my mom i
love
kevin's mom
[Music]
oh i gotta i got a lot more uh job
suggestions if you need one you think
you got it give it to me i'm just gonna
we got lifeguard we got
swim instructor we got ice cream parlor
don't ice cream parlor people come with
little hats yep
ooh if you look up ice cream parlor
outfit you just get a lot of
uncomfortably sexy halloween costumes
jackie what do you know about
kahulu octopus baby he's an octopus baby
octopus baby hey hey
i'm walking here hey hot dog get your
hot dogs
matt are there any questions in the chat
for us ask me
a question i probably won't answer it
but maybe
i will black sheep inc suggests uh
what is your guys favorite cartoons you
go first i have to think about it
my current favorite cartoon is bob's
burgers bob's burgers is amazing
yes but i would say my favorite cartoon
of all time would probably be freakazoid
you remember freakazoid well i mean i
know
from the 90s i know freakazoid but you
know him
i do know personally yes i went to high
school with that get out
yeah is he cool no that's a bummer
it's a bummer you know don't meet your
heroes what's your favorite cartoon i
don't know this one
it's my favorite but i think when i was
a kid the most i've ever
watched of a cartoon was probably
powerpuff girls
i was gonna guess it was some type of
anime like sailor moon or
i guess if oh if we're talking anime as
well
sailor moon sailor moon over naruto yeah
because naruto came kinda later
tiny time lord asks if you were a
superhero
what would your superpower be wow
okay what would be your superpower yours
would be being a squirrel
apparently what do you think i would
have kevin oh are we gonna do it for
each other
let's do it for each other i think it
would get more interesting results
otherwise i might say something stupid
like i wish i
could teleport so i don't have to walk
anymore well that's
actually kind of what i was gonna say
for you
next question how do you feel about
a super speed that's pretty cool i think
i would
love to just flex on people for being
really fast so that's what i would
choose for you what would you choose for
me
mayhaps the power to change someone's
mind
like inception no just like a yes or no
decision
do you want to go get ice cream wait
wait let's try it out do you want to go
get ice cream
yes i don't even like ice cream
you don't like ice cream oh yeah i hate
all things that are fun
how's your drawing coming it's going
pretty good i'm lining i'm having a good
time
as well i got a great question from ruby
artwork love you ruby artwork
how do you color faster are there any
tips and tricks you have to color
a a drawing faster i'll take this one
one thing that i've started to do here
on draw off
learning from jackie is to simply
duplicate my line art layer and
use the paint bucket tool in order to
fill it in now in my world
of print media that is not a good way to
do it because you want to do what's
called trapping
and i'm not going to bore you with what
trapping is
but for screen art it's perfectly
acceptable and it's a much quicker way
to
um to color asami yuzawa
love your song if you could have
contributed to any cartoon or
anime i'm assuming in history what would
it
be it was pretty good wow that is a
great question
spirited away i wish i made that
single-handed just by yourself by myself
i wish i worked on it but i i definitely
was born the year it came out i'm going
to go with freakazoid again freakazoid
yeah i
love that guy it really informed my
sense of humor
what color is cthulhu what does a chat
think
what color should cthulhu be tell you in
a minute what flavor of ice cream should
this be
oh yeah very important
and should it have toppings if so what
kind sprinkles
rainbow sprinkles i mean he's like a
horrifying demon whatever he wants like
blood on it no
no rainbow sprinkles i mean blood just
hits the spot in a different kind of way
hot pink seems to be on the top of the
list all right
and mint chocolate chip is the most
popular flavor here
you guys are weird jackie do you like
drawing live on the internet it has
no positive or negative effects
you are completely neutral about it i
have there's just
no emotion attached there's no emotions
attached to a lot of things you do huh
yeah i think so
are you dead side jacking a little bit
if you look into my eyes if you look
closely
if you if you look
took off my shoes oh jeez okay look
closely
into my eyes you can see that there is
no more happiness or joy
only suffering okay jackie you're
making the internet feel really
uncomfortable
i love this question from andrew blissat
andrew bessette hit us with it who is
your first cartoon crush
oh my god jackie who was your first car
yugi
from yugioh seriously yes oh boy not
yugi but when you geek becomes cool
because he's using the
pyramid whatever yeah i don't really
remember the details
yeah but i was like wow what a guy that
yugi
i also sorry everybody i really like
gary from
pokemon gary gary is like his enemy
oh really yeah oh you like the bad boys
yeah i like the bad ones
but yuki's not bad he's like he's a good
guy yeah yeah but he's
cool like a bad guy nice i'm gonna give
a really lame answer
and a very like white boy answer jessica
rabbit yep
oh my god i hate this i'm sorry
i am done i am also done i have finished
how do you think you did i think i did
wonderfully do you think you did the
internet proud
do you guys like my drawing a lot of
no's
my career is over youtube said i can't
draw
that was just a joke oh see matt
hesitated
matt doesn't like my drawing i think
it's great he says
no i do positivity how do you think you
did
kevin well it definitely looks like me
as a squirrel you know what jackie they
say draw what you know and i know me
and you know you and i know squirrels
and you know squirrels i don't know
squirrels i actually have not seen many
squirrels
i had to pull up a reference for
squirrels because i don't know what
squirrels look like off the top of my
head
it's really really funny why draw a
squirrel from memory right now
you got 30 seconds okay drawing a
squirrel
nap okay
acorn blah blah blah blah blah blah blah
blah
blah
okay well we'll see yeah we'll see i'll
put him
he's the one getting the ice cream
wait what is that noise ah i'm
uncomfortable
it's good it's just scary
uh i like making you uncomfortable with
my drawings yours is adorable
thanks it's you know what when the
internet
suggested it i had a mental image in my
head and this is pretty much what i saw
i drew the squirrel do you like the
squirrel yeah your squirrel is better
than mine you did it in like 30 seconds
congratulations
is that what you want to hear yeah i
just wanted to hear that i'm better than
you in every way and that i
am a perfect and flawless human being
and i can draw literally anything and
everything without looking up reference
was this fun would you have done this oh
yeah that was really fun let's do that
again i did i liked a lot of the
suggestions but the fact that i could
only pick one made it made me picky
we'll have to do it again right yeah
yeah if
you guys want more live streams let's
get some
in the chat everyone just start
screaming let's get some screams in the
chat we get some screams can we get some
blood curdling screams
like murderous screams in the chat like
you are dying of
murder in the chat in the chat please
why are you always gonna make it weird
at the end
hey i'm kyra hey i'm stephanie i'm brent
my name is jason
what are we doing today i have no idea
well today we are doing something that
you in the comments have been asking for
for a while
and the show today
we are going to be drawing each other
wow i was wondering if this would happen
oh my gosh
[Applause]
all right kevin all right jackie can i
draw you cute or should i draw you
oh you draw me however you want to draw
me okay
how should i draw you draw me in your
style my style is just me
okay draw me in your style but improve
upon it so that it
so it doesn't look like me you're that's
a tall order jackie but i will try my
best
what does jason look like i think i'm
just gonna draw you looking down
because that's how i remember you from
working on this show
you've got a big smile actually you've
got more features than i do i feel like
have you done like caricatures
or portraits before i've always had a
hard time with it because people are
like
make me look real like don't be afraid
to make me look ugly and i'm like
stop what if you like get upset what if
i don't do you justice
hmm this is not this is hard this is
hard
yeah should i i feel like i should go
with the cute route
i don't think i should try to draw you
realistically yeah
wait smile jason there you go yeah
that's the jason smiley now i think it's
really hard to draw people that you know
because you don't want to offend them
because you're like even if you're like
no this actually looks good or accurate
you're worried that they might be like
is that really what you think i look
like yeah
[Music]
i'm struggling was this a bad idea it
was a bad idea i think
oh boy but we've already committed we're
doing it we can't stop
we're doing it you have chests here i do
not think i need to see
i think you need to take off your shirt
i need to take off my shirt there's no
other way i'm gonna know
this will feed into the other comments
that think we're in a relationship
what people think that i've seen a few
no i ship it and i show i've shown my
wife i'm like look at this
and she's like tell the comment section
you were married
you are a married man kevin jackie not a
lot of hair
that was mean why would you say that
you do she's not from the front i'm
seeing you in a bra
i know look i know i know i have a huge
forehead so
have fun with it have fun with it i have
a friend that recently got married and
i've been trying to draw
like a portrait of him and his wife and
uh
i've got every like i've got the bodies
figured out i've got everything figured
out
except for the faces like i just have
not been able to
to get the faces down at all i know i
always just end up making people just
cartoons
i'm just like you're just this is your
new face
this is actually kind of my nightmare
because
okay i am not good at likenesses
here's how bad at caricatures i am okay
i actually have a site
okay badcaricatures.com where people can
go
and pay me five dollars to draw a
terrible character of them
i will send them the terrible caricature
and a written apology
you know what kevin there's nothing
wrong with that you know what you're
good at
i know what i'm not good at yeah which
is caricatures did you have that
middle school sketchbook that's just
full of like
beautifully rendered eyes i did a lot of
hands when i was a kid i did a lot of um
epic poses with people with fists yeah i
mean like yeah yeah but that's a fun way
to learn figure drawing is to do comic
characters
yeah so i drew like this funny because
uh my friends would be like
jason can draw anything with muscles
yeah
just boys and their muscle drawings yeah
so everyone would be
ripped the big tip that kind of changed
the way that i drew as a
as a kid was uh draw what you see
don't rely on on symbols and and kind of
your assumption of what something looks
like like actually take time to look
at your subject at the face at the
features
process them as if you've never seen it
before i'm gonna draw you holding a pen
oh cause it will signal that you are an
artist
and this is a portrait of an arches the
whole thing that i've always heard is
like
learn the fundamentals before you break
them yeah because i feel like yeah a lot
of people are like oh well you're just
drawing super cartoony so you can
probably just
you know not need to learn how to draw
realistically it's like no you should
because like
even within the most simple cartoons
there's like intelligent decision making
and like
correct anatomy and proportions yeah you
know even if it looks really obscure
it's still like you can tell that the
person who drew it knows how to draw
[Music]
we just we just look up at each other
we're just looking at each other we're
like what are you just like what do you
look like what do you look like what i
look at you like every time we do this
and i still don't
know what do you look like jack if you
had to assign a celebrity to me
what celebrity would i be i always
struggle with this what's the guy
from 500 days of summer joseph joseph
gordon levin
sign up he's got kind of a very specific
face i feel like
oh what would you decide what celebrity
would you assign me idris elba
it's just wow don't take it back don't
take it i want it
no what what am i doing to you
you look so weird i'm gonna draw your
head a little more bulbous
yeah i do have a bulbous head he's got a
lot of veins
i do have a lot of things sorry
this is just doesn't look like you this
doesn't look like you either
what do we do we continue we keep going
you know this is probably going to lead
to a lot of messages in my inbox being
like hey can you draw me for free
do you do a lot of uh caricature so i've
been like
practicing by drawing friends on my
insta here and there yeah and it's uh
it's been like
really good for capturing like the
essence of of
somebody oh somebody yeah and it's
that's been like really awesome to
to work on i'm drawing you like a bratz
doll
this is not good okay i'm gonna keep
this drawing on the side so you can see
what i started with
but i'm going to go back i'm going to go
cute i'm going to try again
and i think i'm going to go full chibi
full tv yeah
which again is not my style but
i think i may be able to do something
more it kind of made you sort of look
like belle from beauty and the beast
i do like that you have weird eyebrows
thanks jackie not weird like
physically just weird to draw they're an
interesting shape
if you will you know what they call your
eyes kevin what
deep [ __ ] really i've been told they bug
out
deep smooth that's not the thing
i want to do my own horn i think i i
think i might have nailed you
i think i got it if you're 95
smile i think you're pretty much there
drawing jason
i think i nailed you as like male model
brent
whoa so just normal brent no no i just
drew you as yours
yeah yeah thank you how you doing jackie
i mean i'm done
i know you are but i'm trying to make
this other one i made of you even
scarier
how do you think you did i think it made
you look cute like
definitely yeah you're like like a
disney character honestly
it's very cute how about with me i
really enjoyed doing this i haven't done
like a portrait like
in this style in a while and it's it's
really nice it's kind of like um
the like anime that's like trying to be
realistic and
like whisper of the heart kind of style
you seem stressed
kevin you seem stressed this was a lot
harder than i thought it was going to be
yeah you came in thinking it was going
to be easy peasy lemon squeezy yeah
when it was actually hard tea warty
right kevin fargo right
well can i be real for a second okay
it's because i respect you
as an artist and i don't want to
disappoint you
i'm going to cry stop it i mean from
disappointment oh
got em he thought i was mushy you got me
[Applause]
oh my god that's so cute
you made me so cute wow
wow you really got it wow this is me
i love this oh thanks man i love this
too
ah kevin
this is really good stop it kevin
you're just being your anime is getting
great amaze oh it's so cool that's such
a cool style
thank you i love your style too it's
like super expressive
thank you this looks like tv father
jason tv yeah
i had a tv show and i was like the dad
everyone loves yeah
these are great i'm flattered by both of
them i will say the one on the left
though is frightening as hell
it's scary right it's very i'm very
sorry this is a really smart exercise i
feel like especially like
you know if you can't really do life
drawing classes or anything you can just
like grab your friend and be like
sit down i'm gonna draw you yeah or like
have a fun drawing session like this
like i love like when you can just
invite people over and just everybody
can just do art together
i think this looks like me i think this
looks like me oh you did a good job
kevin
thank you i love it and you know what
get rid of your website
because you have drawn a good caricature
thanks friend yeah i want to give you a
hug oh thank you okay
this is a good thing yeah
thank you man thank you i love you man
you